είναι τέτοια κατασταση που θέλουν συνέχως γύρουν το θέμαν θρισκειών τρομοκρατίας και ότε ο κάθεξίς
γιατί υπέρχει και αυτό το το θεσκευτικό στασταημα ου στα ήμις πω ταλι και αυτό
του το πρόλι να τονα τα επειτρίζουν πάρα πολύ διαδή αμέσως επικεινόσαμ μετι κοροπρο και
έχουν μάθει ότι για το δύουλιάσκο ίδη δέκα χώρες τις ευρωπαϊκής ένωσης έχουν υποφέρει αποτέτοιο
δους μηνήματα κοίτασυθεμόλ κάποιές περιπτώσεις ήταν σε σχολία με διαφορετική αλλά παρόμιαν πάντοτε τακτικήαυτό πουκαταλήξαμένοι
είναι ότι μια εταιρεία τηροσία αυτό που θέλαννα πω ότι μιαττην προσέα που προσφέρει ηλεκτρονικά
ηλεκτρονικώ τα χετρούμε σε όποι ο δήμετε θέλεις δηλαδή εγώ μπορώ να τώρα να να
βάω από τα θώσ αυτή διατριαστηρωσία και να δεημιουργήσε έναν ηλεκτροντικών τα χεδρομιογώκάου με τοκούκολο
πως κατοτι γιακούγο τη ήταν α πληρομή και λοιπάν εκεί μπορώ να ξξοπίσεται και ανονημείαν
όμως υτή είναι διαφορά δηλαδή να βάλω αντιαντρέα θα αστασίά υπόνομαμου αβάλω το ομα αντρέας
αντρέου και προσπηικούμεν ότε ομε ο αντρέας αντρέο και να δημιοργήσενα ελεκτρώνικώ τα χεδρομίων και
με τη μέθω των κάποιον ανωνημιών που μπορώ να εφαρμόσω να αποστε οτο αυτό το
μνιι αυτόν εμείς είπαμε ο προπροο παροχαίας το ηλεκτροντικό χιδροίμε ναι με είαι εστηρωσία αλλά
δε σημαίνει αυτό ότι ντ όπως έγινε και με τον πρόεδο ο παροορχέας ένα στα
κατεχόμενα από έστειλε στοίσταγραμ αλλά ότε δε μάθαμε που ήταν εκείνως απου το έστειλε ξεδεν
θα δεν θα πσε αυτό δο ξυζήτησει αντελαμφάντεσται είναι και ιλέ τις τα θέματα και
είναι και επινική υπόθεση ενεξελιξη άρα όμως αυτό π που λέύει γεννικά έχει πάση δηλαδή